okay this is where you kind of bring up
the
the elon musk and the sam harris is
right how far is your intuition
about these kinds of self-playing
mechanisms being able to take us
because it feels one of the
ominous but stated calmly things that
when i talked to david silver he said
is that they have not yet discovered a
ceiling
for alpha zero for example in the game
of go or chess
it's it keeps no matter how much the
compute they throw at it it keeps
improving
so it's possible it's very possible that
you
if you throw you know some like 10x
compute that it will improve by 5x or
something like that
and when stated calmly it's so like
oh yeah i guess so but like and then you
think like well
can we potentially have like uh
continuations of moore's law in totally
different way like broadly defined
moore's law
right not the controversial improvement
exponential improvement like
are we going to have an alpha zero that
swallows the world
uh but notice it's not getting better at
other things it's getting better at
go yeah and i think it's a that's a big
leap to say okay well therefore it's
better at other things well i mean the
the question is how much
of the game of life can be turned into
right so that's of that i think is a
really good question and i think that we
don't i don't think we
as a i don't know community really know
that the answer to this but
um so okay so so i went i went to a talk
uh by some experts on
computer chess so in particular computer
chess
is really interesting because for you
know for of course for
a thousand years humans were the best
chess playing things on the planet
um and then computers like edge to head
of the best person and they've been
ahead ever since it's not like people
have
have overtaken computers but um
but computers and people together have
overtaken computers
right so at least last time i checked i
don't know what the very latest is but
last time i
checked that there were teams of people
who could work with computer programs to
defeat the best computer programs
in the game of go in the game of chess
in the game of chess right and so
using the information about how
these things called elo scores this sort
of notion of how strong a player
are you there's a there's kind of a
range of possible scores and the
you you increment and score basically if
you can
beat another player of that lower score
62 of the time or something like that
like there's some threshold of
if you can somewhat consistently beat
someone then you are of a higher score
than that person
and there's a question as to how many
times can you do that in chess
right and so we know that there's a
range of human ability levels that
cap out with the best playing humans and
the computers went a step beyond that
and computers and people together have
not gone i think a full step beyond that
it feels the estimates that they have is
that it's starting to asymptote
that we've reached kind of the maximum
the best possible
chess playing and so that means that
there's kind of a
finite strategic depth right at some
point you just can't get any better at
this game
yeah i mean i i don't uh so i like to
check that
uh i think it's interesting because if
you have somebody like
uh magnus carlsen who's using these
chess programs
to train his mind like to learn to
become a better chess player yeah
and so like that's a very interesting
thing because
we're not static creatures we're
learning together i mean just like we're
talking about
social networks those algorithms are
teaching us just like we're teaching
those algorithms
so that's a fascinating thing but i
think
the best just playing programs are now
better than the pairs like they have
competition between
paris but the it's still even if they
weren't
it's an interesting question where's the
ceiling so the the david the ominous
david silver
kind of statement is like we have not
found the ceiling
right but so the question is okay so i
don't i don't know
his analysis on that my from talking to
go experts the depth the strategic depth
of go seems to be
substantially greater than that of chess
that there's more kind of
steps of improvement that you can make
get getting better and better and better
but there's no reason to think that it's
infinite yeah uh and so it could be that
it's
that the what david is seeing is the
kind of asymptoting that you can keep
getting better
but with diminishing returns and at some
point you hit
optimal play like in theory all these
finite games
they're finite they have an optimal
strategy there's a strategy that is the
minimax
optimal strategy and so at that point
you can't get any better you can't beat
that that strategy now that strategy may
be
from an information processing
perspective
intractable right that you need
the the all the situations are
sufficiently different that you can't
compress it at all it's this
giant mess of hard-coded rules and we
can never achieve that
but but that still puts a cap on how
many levels of improvement that we can
actually make
but the the the thing about self-play is
if you
if you put it although i don't like
doing that in the broader category of
self-supervised learning is that it
doesn't require
too much or any human human labeling
yeah yeah human label or
just human effort the human involvement
passed a certain point
and the same thing you could argue is
true for
the recent breakthroughs in natural
language processing with language models
oh this is how you get to gpt3 yeah see
how i did the uh
that was a good good transition yeah
yeah i practiced
that for days uh leading up to this guy
now uh
but like that's one of the questions is
can we find ways to formulate problems
in this world that are important to us
humans
like more important than the game of
chess
that uh to which self-supervised kinds
of approaches could be applied whether
it's self-play
for example for like maybe you could
think of like autonomous
vehicles in simulation that kind of
stuff
or just robotics applications and
simulation
or in the self-supervised learning
where unannotated
data or data that's generated by humans
naturally without extra cost like
the wikipedia or like all of the
internet
can be used to learn something about
to create intelligent systems that do
something uh really
powerful that pass the turing test or
that
do some kind of superhuman level
performance
so what's your intuition like trying to
stitch all of it together about
our discussion of agi the limits of
self-play
and your thoughts about maybe the limits
of neural networks in the context of
language models is there some intuition
in there that might be
useful to think about yeah yeah yeah so
so first of all the the whole
transformer network family of
things um is really cool it's really
really cool
i mean for you know if you've ever back
in the day you played with
i don't know mark off models for
generating text and you've seen the kind
of text that they spit out
and you compare it to what's happening
now it's
it's amazing it's so amazing now it
doesn't take very long
interacting with one of these systems
before you find the holes
right it's it's not smart in any kind of
general way it's really good at a bunch
of things and it does seem to understand
a lot of the statistics of language
extremely well
and that turns out to be very powerful
you can answer many questions with that
but it doesn't make it a good
conversationalist right and doesn't make
it a good storyteller it just makes it
good at imitating of things it is seen
in the past the exact same thing could
be said by people who voting for donald
trump about joe biden supporters and
people voting for joe bidenball donald
trump supporters
is uh you know that they're not
intelligent they're just following
the yeah they're following things
they've seen in the past and uh
so it's very it doesn't take long to
find the flaws
in their uh in their like
natural language generation abilities
yes yeah so we're being very
that's interesting critical events
right so so i've had a similar thought
which was that
the stories that gpt-3 spits out
are amazing and very human-like
and it doesn't mean that computers are
smarter than we realize necessarily it
partly means that people are dumber than
we realize
or that much of what we do day to day
is not that deep like we're just we're
just kind of
going with the flow we're saying
whatever feels like the natural thing to
say next
not a lot of it is is is creative or
meaningful or
or intentional but enough is that we
actually get
we get by right we do come up with new
ideas sometimes and we do
manage to talk each other into things
sometimes and we do sometimes
vote for reasonable people sometimes
but um but it's really hard to see in
the statistics because so much of what
we're saying is kind of rote
and so our metrics that we use to
measure how these systems are doing
don't reveal that because it's it's it's
in the interest this is
that that is very hard to detect but is
your
do you have an intuition that with these
language models
if they grow in size it's already
surprising that when you go from gpt2 to
gpg3
that there is a noticeable improvement
so the question now goes back to the
ominous david silver and the ceiling
right so maybe there's just no ceiling
we just need more compute now
i mean okay so now i'm speculating yes
as opposed to before when i was
completely on firm yeah all right um
i don't believe that you can get
something that really
can do language and use language as a
thing that doesn't
interact with people like i think that
it's not enough to just take
everything that we've said written down
and just say that's enough you can just
learn from that and you can be
intelligent
i think you really need to be pushed
back at
i think that conversations even people
who are pretty smart
maybe the smartest thing that we know
not maybe not the smartest thing we can
imagine
but we get so much benefit out of
talking to each other and interacting
that's presumably why you have
conversations live with guests is that
that there's
something in that interaction that would
not be exposed by
oh i'll just write your story and then
you can read it later and i think
i think because these systems are just
learning from our stories they're not
learning from
being pushed back at by us that they're
fundamentally limited into what they
could actually become
on this route they have to they have to
get
you know shut down like we like we have
to have an argument that
they have to have an argument with us
and lose a couple times before they
start to realize
oh okay wait there's some nuance here
that actually matters
yeah that's actually subtle sounding but
quite profound that the interaction with
humans is essential
and the limitation within that is
profound as well because
the time scale like the bandwidth at
which you can really interact with
humans
is very low so it's costly so you can't
one of the underlying things about self
plays it has to do
you know a very large number of
interactions
and so you can't really deploy
reinforcement learning systems
into the real world to interact like you
couldn't deploy a language model
into the real world to interact with
humans because
it would just not get enough data
relative to
the cost it takes to interact like the
time of humans is
is expensive which is really interesting
that's that go that takes us back to
reinforcing learning
and trying to figure out if there's ways
to
make algorithms that are more efficient
at learning keep the spirit and
reinforcement learning
and become more efficient
you